hello and welcome to the evan carmichael
show i believe in entrepreneurs and
it's time
it's time that your business takes off
it's time that all the energy and hard
work and effort and money and dedication
that you put into this
actually start yielding some results and
i know that it's hard and i know that
you know you have people in your life
who may not believe in you
and you may not believe in yourself
anymore you may have hit some threshold
and you feel like you just can't bust
through it and i want to help you i want
to help you get through that that
barrier that is holding you back
i have an exciting show today today's
show is all about success on the agenda
what is success how do you create a
movement how do you find the one word to
rally everybody around and what is your
greater responsibility as an
entrepreneur now what is success this is
a great question i got asked by somebody
on my youtube channel what is excessive
and what's your definition
and to me it's actually pretty easy to
me it's just happiness
i want happiness in my life i want to be
i want to be happy i want to do things
that make me happy and in general i'm a
pretty happy person but
for every person that definition of
happiness is different you know for me
it's success isn't about how much money
you make every year what's in your bank
account not it's not what kind of car
you drive it's about
the happiness and so how do i get
happiness for me it comes to three
things and hopefully some learning here
for you
first is freedom
i need freedom to be happy i need to be
in control of of what i do when i do it
with who i do it
so there's probably no surprise that i
became an entrepreneur right if you're
making a million dollars a year but
you're working 100 hours a week
you can't enjoy your money right you
can't enjoy you're not in control of
your time and so you don't have the
freedom to be happy that's not success
in my view
number two is growth
growth
i have to be learning something new you
know i find a lot of entrepreneurs have
this challenge too where they are
they're not learning anything they're
stagnating they're doing the same thing
every day and you get to the point where
it's like
i can't take this anymore this isn't
working for me i got to do something
different
you need growth the growth can come from
something within your business the
growth can come from your personal life
you know for me it might be working on a
new radio show idea maybe working on a
new website idea in my personal life and
maybe traveling with family to a new
place they may be learning some news
awesome moves there's always growth you
need to have growth in your life to stay
happy
and the last one is impact
an impact this is the most important one
of the three i'd give up freedom and
growth that has impact
impact is
helping other people
you want to have an impact in your life
and with your business think of when
you're happiest it's when you're helping
somebody it may have been helping a
buddy get out of a gym it may have been
helping some random stranger on the
street and maybe delighting your
customers with your service but you're
helping people you're having an impact
and as entrepreneurs you want to make
sure that you're having an impact with
your company
that's what will make you successful
that's what will make you happy
so push forward on it and don't get so
locked up into i need to earn x amount
of dollars to be happy because i promise
you that's not the past
i have michael on the line michael where
are you from and how can i help
i'm uh from shreveport louisiana street
fort welcome to the program what's going
on thank you thank you well um i
certainly enjoy your topic their success
i've i've enjoyed a lot of success with
what i do i have a niche
wildlife control business
i uh i go out and i rescue people daily
from uh from wild animals that have
entered their homes and so so it gets a
lot of job satisfaction a lot of all my
customers are very gracious that i
showed up
and gratitude is awesome
but um but i find myself at a crossroads
and a dilemma i converted my wildlife
company to a franchise
five years ago
now the franchise has been sold and
myself and the current owners are
we're not getting along and so
i'm going to dissolve the franchise and
in doing that i'm going to be coming up
against the non-compete
clause that's
pretty significant it's pretty it's
fairly solid of course anything can be
litigated but i don't want to go down
that route
so i just want if you might have any
ideas
about how i can still operate
yet
avoid that non-compete clause
it's you who has the non-compete or the
franchisees who are now being dissolved
the franchise
you can still do
the business you're worried about the
franchisees who are no longer
franchisees running the same company
well i'm i'm the franchisee they are the
franchisor
oh you're the franchisee
okay how long does it last the well um
upon termination is 24 months
is there a component to it that you can
do
that doesn't inflict on that non-compete
no there's not and and the non-compete
is very geographic in nature
right okay so can you go to a different
market
i can i can and that's one of the things
i'm contemplating right now is going to
a different market
there's
i had four markets
and so the non-compete will
not allow me to operate in any of those
four four markets
okay
and this is what you love doing right
michael this is what you love
it's a passion
you know it's it's not work it's i get
up every morning i'm excited i mean i'm
just one of those people that spring out
of bed because i've got so many
different things to do it's never the
same and i control my own schedule while
the customers do but you know what i
mean
yeah yeah i love it so how far away is
the next market that you can go into
well you know that's not an issue i'm uh
you know i own property and i'm very
mobile i've got liquid assets
um but the the the two markets that i'm
looking at or the one i'm looking at the
most is four hours away
and it would it would include a complete
overhaul
would you have to move are you willing
to move your family to do that
yeah luckily my 18 year old son is about
to graduate
and uh and my wife is extremely
supportive
that's great do you see this as a
permanent move or something that will
get you through the next two years and
then come back
actually you know it's funny you should
mention that because the way i think of
this projecting out 10 years
i'm like
if i made a move for the next 24 months
i could really establish an office in
that location
and then after that i'd be open to go
anywhere i want
if that's not if that doesn't turn out
to be just the best place
do you want to be able to franchise this
yourself like do you want more offices
and people under you when you build this
up yourself i don't i don't want to
franchise it myself but
people are attracted to me and i i tend
to find really really really exceptional
people to work with me and and they just
they want to work for me that's not like
they just want the job what you could do
here michael is you could use your
scenario here as a as a proof of concept
you're saying i'm going to this market
you know it's four hours away i've never
been there before and i'm gonna set up
shop and make it successful and that
could be a blueprint for anybody else to
go and do the same thing if you wanted
to have somebody under you open up a new
location i think you're on the right
path you love this it's great that you
have found your life's passion because
so many people haven't done that yet so
you have to keep going you have to do
this the two years is a long time but in
the grand scheme of things it's not that
long a time right you're already talking
the 10-year plan
two years is not that long on that plan
and you can use this as your off point
to
to prove to yourself that you can do it
but then also show others that no i'm
not from this area and i moved in here
it's four hours away i started from
nothing and i built it up you can create
that blueprint that you can either then
if you didn't want to franchise as far
but you could open up new markets or you
can even sell a guide for other people
to launch in markets across the united
states and say hey here's how you open
up a new market and get it going quickly
yeah it's great that you have a
supportive family who's willing to do
this with you
because that's that's one of the biggest
challenges again convincing them to you
know follow your dream with you
oh absolutely well i do have a very
supportive family
but i also have
i don't know what it is but i'm able to
run into people
that um immediately want to
get on board and support and
and just want to help propel me forward
and that's why i've been successful i
mean i opened up four offices
from scratch
with very little capital and i've never
had to borrow money
i love it michael i love it keep going
keep keep pursuing your mission your
vision i love it you found your life
class and you need to keep going on this
thank you so much for calling in
thanks evan
welcome back to the evan carmichael show
i believe in entrepreneurs in our last
segment i was talking about what is
success and how you need to have an
impact to help other people to get
success and get happiness for yourself
and in your business the next step up
from that is creating a movement now
this is impact on a larger scale so it's
not just helping
you know your buddies in a crisis or
delighting a customer at a time it's
larger scale helping thousands or
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people
that's creating a movement one of my
favorite examples here is about uh steve
jobs co-founder of apple steve jobs was
a multi-millionaire in his early 20s
a multi-millionaire in his early 20s he
didn't have to work for the rest of his
life if he didn't want to what do you do
when you have that much money in your
early 20s but what did steve jobs do he
kept working at apple
until the day he died
he was working at apple and why did he
do it it wasn't because he was trying to
make a lot of money he had enough money
it was because he wanted to create
something important
in his own words he wanted to create a
dent in the universe he was motivated to
do something bigger to create a movement
and his primary focus was never on the
money it's funny because steve jobs here
his focus was never number one on the
money and yet he went on to build the
most valuable company in the world at
one point
according to market capitalization
how does that happen
it's because when you pour yourself into
something and you're really impacting
people on a big scale in a lot of ways
you build your movement and it starts
taking off and it's something that is
deep and core to you something that you
love doing
that's why i took off for him
if your focus is just on the money
you're never gonna make it you're never
gonna build anything solid successful
massive growth and having that impact on
a lot of people
so think about what your movement can be
i have lance on the line lance where are
you from and how can i help well i'm
lance great house i'm from phoenix
arizona
and i recently opened my a new a
non-profit called the wheelchair lab and
i'm doing it part-time and i work a
full-time job as a dental repairman but
what i want to do is do this wheelchair
lab full-time
and basically what it is is we fix up
old wheelchairs that are donated to us
and we donate them to people that can't
afford wheelchairs
and i got a small grant that allows me
to get parts and chairs
you know but not a salary out of this so
i'm trying to figure a way that i can
i also build barbecues and different
things and try to sell they'll to
support the non-profit the wheelchair
lab
which like i said we build electric
wheelchairs custom ones refurbish them
and give them out to people that can't
afford them
is it a non-profit or not for profit
it's a non-profit i just opened it i'm
under another non-profit it's one of
their arms called the southwest
community network and i'm under them
right now and we're able to donate maybe
five or six wheelchairs a month to
people that can't afford or don't have
insurance yeah and i love it awesome
that's awesome and the most really
fulfilling for you
it is it's um my younger brother ended
up with a rare form of parkinson's and
ended up in a wheelchair
and i noticed how everybody treated him
different so i started building really
custom wheelchairs with stereos and
and lights and big tires and custom and
everybody started treating them
different so
what my passion is is just building
custom wheelchairs and donating to
people
the the path to you know keeping this
thing alive to raising money is
typically through corporate sponsors
do you have corporations who are on
board with you
i do not this is all just just me myself
right now i don't know how to go about
that i've approached a few people in the
in the past but i didn't have much luck
getting sponsors for it
you know so two thoughts i have how
about once you're part of a bigger
charity already right there they're kind
of sponsoring you and giving you the you
know the non-profit
um license
they have sponsors can you can you
approach some of their corporate
sponsors and say hey this is part of the
same charity they're already donating to
that charity would they consider
helping you out here
i can try that i don't know if they have
a lot of people donating right now or
they're working with but that's and i
said this is brand new
um yeah
so i'm not sure
so it's making a list i mean the other
thing i would think of is trying to
partner up with any handicapped
associations
or people who are
making these wheelchairs or supporting
people who are in wheelchairs or
supporting you know veterans who come
back and need wheelchairs any of those
other non-profits and seeing who
is on uh which corporate sponsors are
supporting them
and getting involved because it's hard
for you to go to a corporation and say
you know hey here's this new initiative
if they have no tie already to the
charity or to
wheelchairs in any way
so it's better to find people who
already have an interest for some reason
in it
and have them
you'll be exposed to what you're doing
and see why it's so important
right i do work with the veterans
association right now uh shining star
program and the local va
but they haven't they don't really seem
to have a lot of corporate uh
sponsorship at all it's all like through
the government
right
so part of it what you what you need to
do is be able to story tell really well
so
you know you're doing five wheelchairs a
month i would take one of those people
who have their story left a profound
impact on you because they must have
crazy stories these guys must have they
must be so happy that you came and
helped them
raises people with no money no insurance
they can't afford it their life they're
struggling because they don't have a
wheelchair you come in and you you save
them
well i get thank yous all the time and
they'll still call me back two or three
weeks down the road and months and just
saying how it's changed their life and
how grateful they are and they want to
help you know help me help me uh keep
doing what i'm doing and help other
people so that's my long-term goal
right another thing as i said i built a
lot of stuff like i said barbecues and
other custom things i'm trying to see if
there's a way that i could sell them and
use that money to put into the nonprofit
is there any is there a way to do that
you can for sure
um
i guess it's figuring out what your
passion is going to be right i think you
have a bigger opportunity to get people
on board to support you in building the
wheelchairs for for what they are right
if it's corporate sponsorship or using a
website like kickstarter.com
i think you can build this out and get
the dollars you need without having to
open a new business to support it i mean
if the barbecue business is your passion
too and you love doing that
then you can but it's still it's small
because you're splitting your time
the wheelchair is my main passion i'm
just trying to find ways to fund that
so i can do that full-time it's not so
much money as i needed i need time i
need to be able to concentrate all my
time
on the non-profit side
yeah and you need to you need to still
be able to pay yourself
a living right
right
basically just to get it get it up and
running exactly yeah
yeah i would try to get some of those
stories down
you know get three really good stories
of people who you have helped personally
and they're just overwhelmed and have
them tell their story and ideally even
on video if you can
and use that
i would look at you know look at
kickstarter.com
it's a way to raise funds through
through the public
and look at corporate sponsors who have
already donated to things related to the
wheelchair
anything related to wheelchairs and
veterans
right and show them the stories
if it's a powerful moving story they'll
want to get involved
awesome okay okay well thank you all
right good luck lance no problem thank
you very much
it's great when you find your passion
and you know you're helping people the
past two callers have been amazing on
that you have to find a way to keep
going and i don't recommend splitting up
your time
between you know he's a he's a dental
repairman he's he wants to you know make
barbecue then he wants to do this focus
your time on one thing make it amazing
and you'll see great results today we've
been talking about success we've been
talking about impact we've been talking
about building your movement
the next step here is to pick your one
word okay there is one word that defines
who you are if somebody had to write a
one-word biography for you what would it
be
some people find it really easy to find
their one word other people have a
challenge with it but here's why it's
important okay the one word makes it
easy for you to make decisions and it
makes it easy for people to talk about
you
to find your one word think about the
books you like to read the friends that
you have the movies you watch the songs
you listen to the companies that you've
worked for the ones you've created
quotes that you enjoy art that you like
looking at think about all the things
that you love in your life
there's a common scene that brings all
of these together there's a common theme
between the books you love and the
quotes you love and the friends that you
have there's a common theme between them
for me it's belief
that's my one word i i love the story of
of things that where people believed in
them and they took off i love the story
of the little guy who becomes successful
one of my favorite movies of all time is
seabiscuit or this little horse that
everybody said was never gonna make it
and he goes on to win all these races
i love that story i love the store
people believing and so that makes it
easy for me to build my movement around
belief you need to find what's yours
okay
so here's an example a buddy of mine
runs a training company
and his is helping companies get
delighted he wants people to be
delighted he's a big customer service
fanatic
and so every experience with his company
has to be delightful now he could sell
anything
but he brings that value of his
delightful into the business how does it
help
there's two things one for every
decision that he makes in his business
it has to be around delighting the
customer it's not then you don't take it
it makes it super easy so you're
bringing on a new employee to your
company they have to share that same
word they have to want to delight
customers if they don't they're not in
it's easy
i don't put something up on my website
or talk about on my radio show if it
doesn't relate to belief
so it makes all your decisions easier
the other thing though that it makes it
easy to do with customers to talk about
you you need it to be easy for people to
talk about your business this is a
really complicated world people are
bombarded with messages all the time and
if your message is too difficult to
explain
then nobody's going to share it
right you have to make it easy
so my buddy louie with this training
company it's easy for people to say this
guy really delights people
he's a delightful training company it's
easy to share that message
and so he'll get more business
if you have a complicated convoluted you
know three sentence long mission
statement
nobody remember you can't even remember
that
nobody else is going to remember that
so you have to get it down to one word
this is a personal word this is
something that is of value to you it's
not anything related to what you sell
it's not your products or your services
it's a core value that you have
again it's your one word biography make
it simple make it easy you may already
have it right now
pump that into everything that you're
doing if you don't then spend the time
to really think about what that one word
is for you because it will change
yourself and your business i have katie
on the line katie where are you from and
how can i help hi there i'm from
harrisburg pennsylvania and i have a
business idea that is based on pandora
for travel it's like the pandora for
travel it's a website with an algorithm
that will predict the type of trip that
you like
based on your personality
that's really cool so
it's a fun idea
so our challenge is that i have a team
i'm working with we met at a startup
weekend not too long ago and
we we have a good team made up of a web
designer a web programmer um my myself
on the marketing side of things and
content development and the original guy
that had the idea who's also a digital
marketer
but among our team we don't really have
the capability to
build out the complexity of the
algorithm that we need we we need to
attract some sort of you know intense
data architect or programmer that can
handle the complexity of our our concept
and also attract investors um so that we
can build it out to that next level
there's no way for you to start with
what you've got
um you know we are trying to build out
some model algorithms that can
demonstrate what we um have in mind
and we're working on that again we're
also battling you know everybody has
full-time jobs elsewhere so that's how
it goes
but
we we know we have a strong concept
we've built out a business model around
it and how to monetize
we're looking at tapping into
open apis with expedia travelocity
things like that for booking making a
simple one-click booking
service um as well so once it predicts a
trip you like it narrows down the
choices to you know the hotels and the
types of activities that already knows
you're going to
gravitate to and makes the choice
simpler and then it's one click
booking step
what you need is one feature to make
people say
wow even forgetting about the booking
part yet like if it's just helping me
find a trip
get that up
and make me say that's what you talked
about on when you came on the show i
said i want to try this
right that's all you need to launch with
you need to launch and get people using
it
to the point where they say wow okay
and then you can worry about all the
other things so don't let this it's easy
to get caught up in how many features
you need and then you don't do anything
so you've got to get it to that point
investors if you go for investment now
you're going to get killed on your
valuation kill right if you only have an
idea
it's not the time you need to go out and
and get users and get people
on the system and then it's easier for
investors to come on and say hey you
already have this traction oh i see a
clear revenue model here i'm going to
give you your funding
if you're really missing that algorithm
guy again look for ways to bootstrap it
i'd even go to your local university
and find
a student program or find a professor
who might be able to recommend this
student to work on a project as an
internship with you guys like this is a
fun cool exciting project you just need
a math mask to help you
get that algorithm off the off the
ground right right right
yeah we also explored the concept of you
know looking at different tech
incubators and potentially you know
working with them to develop the concept
further until we're ready to you know
build out users and and create our
our monetization model
you can a lot of time to the incubator
so that becomes a full-time thing so are
you guys all willing to take your job to
go do this
and honestly that will be something that
will come up is how many of you four of
you five of you
um there's four now there were six
originally but two dropped out
okay and that will happen you will have
probably more people drop out
so who is leading this thing and who
really wants to commit to it to the
point where at some point they're
actually going to quit their jobs to do
this thing full time okay because it's
not going to come just from an investor
an investor doesn't want to come on to
pay salary right an investor wants to
come on to build this thing up so
it's something to keep in mind like who
is really important on this team and
who's really dedicated to making this
thing happen
yeah absolutely well and you know i have
the capacity to uh to go full time right
now i'm i'm currently self-employed um
would be willing to uh go after it but
um i i
don't have the skill set to do it myself
in terms of the development so
okay
hero
is our
concept so hopefully you'll see it in
the future what's it called getaway hero
getaway hero okay i want to know when it
launches because i'm definitely going to
check it out but what you should be
focused on right now is one main feature
that will make people say wow
just help me find a trip like if that's
it help me find the trip don't you don't
have to help me book it you don't have
to help me find the hotels or don't
worry about the apis for expedia or
anything yet like that will all come
but help me find an amazing trip
if i use your software your website and
i say wow i'm going to talk about on
this radio show you know i'm going to
talk about it on my twitter newsletter
right you want people spreading the word
and if you get lots of users
on your website
then it's easy to attract investors it's
easier to see your revenue model you
know all of that everything else becomes
easier but you got to get the users and
it comes from one thing that makes
people say wow got it
so good luck keep me posted i want to
see your success
thank you so much i appreciate your
advice
no problem thanks katie so for everybody
who's who's trying to launch a business
trying to get it going especially a
partner it can be hard but you need to
find one thing that will get people
talking
one thing that will make people say wow
and start using it so you can get some
feedback and get some investment and get
more people on your team and build this
thing up we need to get this thing
started because an investor is not
coming in at the very early stage to
save you you've got to figure this out
yourself at least to get it off the
ground
welcome back to kevin carmichael show
i'm sleeping entrepreneurs today's been
a fun show talking about success talked
about having an impact we talked about
creating a movement we talked about
finding your one word to wrap it all up
you need to now tap into your greater
responsibility i believe that you have a
responsibility to now also help people
who are on the same path as you who have
the same one word as you who has the
same mission as you because
they may be doubting themselves too
they may be having a hard time as well
and your your voice your support can
make the difference between them staying
on their path and then leaving it one of
my favorite stories is of
martin luther king
and lieutenant uhura so if you know if
you guess you guys who are star trek
fans lieutenant ahura was on the
original star trek she was i think third
in command on the on the on the
spaceship and
after the first season of the show she
wanted to leave she's like you know what
i think i could do more than just his
acting and and i want to expand my
career and and do other things
and it was important because she was the
first black person in any position of
power on tv if you looked on any tv show
black people were servants they were
delivery people they never had any power
and here she was
third in command
on this new show but she just didn't
want to do it anymore
and after she quit she got a call from
martin luther king
and martin luther king
told her
i understand you know what you're trying
to do for personal reasons but what
you're doing with star trek here this is
important
you're inspiring millions of americans
you're inspiring them to show there's
hope you're a hero for them
you have to keep going
and she never saw what she was doing as
being that important
until martin luther king stepped in
what he did so well was find people
who were
on the same path as he was which was
equal rights
and find ways to support them and
believe in them and that's what you need
to do with your business as well you
need to find people who are also on the
same path who believe in the same things
you do who have the same one word as you
do on the same mission
and find ways to support them
reach out
help them
be a supportive voice just believe in
them so for me i believe in
entrepreneurs
i love helping entrepreneurs
and
one of my things i don't think there's
enough education out there for
entrepreneurs especially on tv now you
look at tv what's on tv
there's not a lot to help entrepreneurs
you want comedies you want dramas you
want actions a lot but but information
to help entrepreneurs you can get a lot
online you get a lot on radio stations
you can't get a lot on tv
there's sharks tank
right sharks tank in canada we have one
called dragon's den but that's it so
there's this new show launching called
the prophet they're in their second
season now
and it's a great show where there's an
angel investor who goes in and he puts
his money into new businesses and
supports them
and
it didn't do that well it was okay it's
you know getting a little bit of an
audience you know the person on the show
was trying to figure out his voice
and so i reached out to them and said
hey what you're doing is important keep
it up
great work just to support him
and he wrote back and he's appreciative
you need to do the same thing
and it may be
on a big scale like somebody's doing a
tv show maybe a celebrity but it may be
just somebody who you know or somebody
online
find people who believe in the same
thing you do and be a force for good
and even though it may seem like there's
no
direct business impact
there will be
i promise you
it will come back to support you and
help you build something extremely
powerful
so the guy from the prophet his name is
marcus lemonis
you know i didn't go out there and offer
him anything i didn't say hey let's do a
deal together here's how i can help
i'm just supporting him
and now he knows about me
and even though there's no direct
business relationship right now that's
gonna help me it's gonna come back it
comes back so many times so many times
where i've helped people
it always comes back and it also makes
you feel good
if you're out there
helping people
and seeing that what you're doing
is helping them continue on on the
mission which is the same as yours it
makes you feel so good and it gives you
energy to pour back into your company
right half the battle with entrepreneurs
is just perseverance how do you keep
going when times get really tough and
crappy
so that's one way to do it you have a
greater responsibility to help the
people in your networks
i'm going to hit up twitter for a
question i got a question from uh from
jane who's in chicago to write in to say
how do i use social media
how do you use social media see
this could go on i don't have a lot of
time left in the show but what i would
do with social media
is again
make it about your one word and your
movement
share things that are meaningful to you
share things that are important to you a
lot of times you're just out there
broadcasting stuff right you just
blocked out you're putting out your
promotions your sales you know you're
saying come by for me now here's a 20
coupon you know that stuff is not
working anymore
are you getting any results from your
social media probably not and i don't
want it to be a big waste of time for
you but it is important
what it allows you to do is build an
audience build a following and what you
want to do is share the things that get
you excited
share things that are important to you
that make your heart beat if it's
pictures or videos or quotes you read a
story that you like put it up and
explain why
your company
should be at the front
of this movement
so if you look at my social media
channel i have my own quotes things that
i believe in for entrepreneurs but i
also share quotes from famous
entrepreneurs people like steve jobs
people that go for winfrey things that
inspire them because it makes me
inspired and that helps inspire other
entrepreneurs and i'm not putting out
hey come by my my guides hey come you
know listen to this show i'm not doing
all the promotional stuff because if
that's all i did people would tune out
they wouldn't care
but by consistently providing value
and value i think is important for me
that i love and putting that out
people tune in and they listen and they
share they do it automatically and then
they buy because i built that
relationship up so start by sharing
things that you love build the
relationship put out things that are
important and people will be attracted
to you and then if you build that
relationship they'll buy whatever you
have they can't wait to buy the next
thing that you have
that's how you use social media
effectively
it's not out there spamming people
we're already up at the end of our hour
it's crazy i want to thank
lauren and fernanda my producers
lord is away next week on vacation have
a great time off in pittsburgh and we'll
see everybody in two weeks everybody
keep building your businesses and keep